I Whoa, where am I?
Give me a sec.
I'll show up soon.
I swear to God guys.
Give me that.
It's like I'm oh there I am.
Whoa.
Oh, I Forgot one thing Messy today, I think I feel like I've been messy with my whole life, but today I'm extra messy.
All right guys.
Sorry Well guys might be if guys don't follow me on Twitter and twitch good for you Okay, so you for those who just follow me on YouTube or like What are you doing here?
I thought you're gonna be on twitch today.
Well, long story short.
I have an articles written about me apparently
Technically you could sort of Google what I what happened and why
Oh Every time I feel like oh my god, why does this always happen the first month of the
Papa smear.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you a green stoke.
You're right.
That's my first lady I'm a volunteer soldier who wish to remain on this and I'll say Actions.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
It's the ancient dragoon I Think it was yo feudal dragoon.
Thank you a super chat.
Thank you thing.
Yeah It is tradition.
No, I swear to God like I I ventured out of my I ventured out of my YouTube bubble and then this we got into twitch drama and then we were like laughing at twitch drama and then I I Ventured out.
I was like, let me explore on twitch for the two weeks for two weeks I was only on twitch regularly for two weeks and I somehow got into one of the biggest twitch Not the one of the biggest it wasn't even long live stream fell cuz they don't give a fuck But like I somehow got into a 2025 first one No second twitch drama there's pirate software the second twitch drama of the year Two weeks out of my youtube bubble and now I'm here now
I am not in the Twitch Rivals, and I don't know if I'll ever be participating in future Twitch Rivals.
I know it's weird, I like, suddenly just burned that bridge down, but like, I don't know, I was really upset with what happened.
And like, with what happened in the end, because I did try to take precautions to like, I was like, Are you sure?
Like, do we need to change teammates?
Like, for the last week, I was like, messaging, asking Twitch staff, like, what's going on?
And they're like, nothing is going on.
It's all just rumors.
So then like, I was like, okay.
And then I was like, live blogging it to you guys too, during pre-chat as well, while this was happening.
And a lot of these rumors were going on, and I don't know, I don't know if I'm actually gonna burn that bridge, I don't know.
Because like, right now, like, I... Because like, you guys have seen my history and journey with Twitch rivals.
And like, I've been in some incredibly unfair Twitch rivals, but I've never like, I've just sucked it up, like...
Like, and then like, I just laugh it off.
I was lied to about some Twitch rivals, where I thought they would be casual.
Casual, but they're not.
They're like, actual, like, teams stack their... Teams stack their players.
So like, but I've always sucked it up, and just be like, oh well, free money, ha ha ha.
And so like, and then like, when I made my team, I already saw that teams were already big.
This was the first time, because I was really passionate about this game.
I was very passionate about Marvel Rivals.
And um, and I was like, I really wanted to know what the competition is like, because I actually really want to do really well in it.
Because so, before I even gave them my team, the team I wanted to join with, I asked them for a teams list.
Like, what other players were doing.
So I know if this is a competitive, or if it was like, actual just content creators.
And then obviously, I saw the teams list of those who have already confirmed their teams, or like...
Who like, and then I've heard about what, like, captains who haven't yet confirmed their teams with staff.
But like, I've heard from other players, because I've asked around, like, who they were getting.
And I realized, I told you guys this too when I got invited.
I realized, like, this is gonna be either stacked...
Stacked teams versus, like, I even told you guys, oh yeah, there's like a team that's sort of like Minecrafters.
And then there's gonna be like, teams where it's like, people who can actually aim, and stuff like that.
And then, so, I saw that, and I told you guys, when I told, the very first, one of the very first streams when I told you guys about the invitation.
I was like, I know you guys want me to invite other content creators, but I don't want to get spawncams.
I was like, I know it's not enjoyable, and I had, I picked, because I was like, they're not, I thought they weren't gonna change the rules.
Because every time I participated in Twitch Rivals, they've never changed the rules.
And I've always been on the, on the bad end of the stick.
I've always been like, I didn't get absolute shit on.
And I just had to like, uh, uh, I just had to like, roll it off, and was like, oh well, I guess I get free money.
Like, so I thought nothing was gonna be done about it.
Um, and, and I even asked them, I was like, are you guys gonna change the rules?
Is my team gonna have to change?
And stuff like that, multiple times, I've asked them multiple times.
And they're like, nope, nope, it's, it's just rumors, nothing's gonna be happening.
Um, so like, this was the very first time I've, uh, had, I realized they are actually gonna change the rules.
And it was like, 24 hours before the tournament.
And every team has like, done scrims, done scrims, done practices.
Um, like, bonded with their teams and everything.
And, uh, and like, I thought, I was like, okay.
Obviously, I wasn't very happy, um, about it, because I felt like, uh, I even, I, I wouldn't be as unhappy if like, it came out of nowhere, you know?
Like, um, like, I even double checked rankings and everything for my entire team, making sure everybody is like, the actual rank and everything.
Within the guidelines, I double checked with Twitch staff multiple times, and I double checked, like, are, are you sure it's okay?
I grabbed 4 1 above alls, including me.
I was like, are you sure?
Are you sure that's okay?
And they're like, yeah, it's alright.
I was like, yeah, you can get 4 1 above alls?
I was like, are you sure?
And like, do you have any pro players?
I was like, well, they participated in Marvel Rise tournament, um, and like, uh, RaiMazing was a tier 2 player, not even tier 1.
He never, he, um, he didn't get into, like, Overwatch League or was part of any, like, tier 1 orgs or anything.
Uh, RaiMazing wasn't a tier 2.
Um, there are some players that are currently playing, there are tier, that used to be in tier 1 orgs and stuff like that.
And, and so like, so like, I was just like, oh, okay.
That's why I was mad.
That's why I was very mad.
That's why I was very disappointed about all of them.
Um, and, uh, I was, cause I even tried to avoid this from happening.
Cause even my teammates were like, are you sure we're allowed to play?
And I double checked with staff, I quadruple checked with them, and they were like, no, it's fine.
I was like, are you sure?
These, this is their history.
This is what they do.
Are you sure?
And they're like, yeah, it's fine.
So that's why I brought the team I had, because like, I had access to the teams list that were like, already confirmed.
And I heard about what people were, who they were bringing.
So I was like, I don't, I want at least, like, I don't want to get absolute stomped on.
Because I've had to experience that so many times in Twitch Rivals.
But I laughed it off and like, just was like, whatever.
Okay, that's fine.
Like, yeah, they sort of, I just felt like I got fucked over because, you know, they were gonna say it was casual, but it ended up not being casual.
I was like, whatever.
Like, we did, I did my, I, you know, they needed a fill.
I said yes, because like, I'm fine with filling if they needed an extra person.
And, and then they're like, and then so like, knowing that I was like, Marvel Rivals was actually a game that I actually really, really liked.
I really, really liked Marvel Rivals.
You know, I still love Marvel Rivals.
So I was like, at that point, I was like, I'm gonna take this seriously.
I want to be sure, and I want to take this seriously.
I really like Marvel Rivals.
I want to do really well in this Marvel Rivals tournament.
Because it was considered one of the, um, one of the first, like, tournaments for Marvel Rivals that I could join as a content creator.
Um, because usually in the past, I'm grouped as a professional player, because of my rankings.
Like, even as an Apex player, I, my Pred rank was all, was sometimes considered the same as an actual pro player Pred.
And I'm like, no, it's not.
Like, also, I haven't been Pred in a fucking long time.
So like, I always had to deal with situations like this.
So I was like, oh my God, yeah, I get to actually be a part of this and like, even participate despite being a high rank.
And so like, um, so like, but then, in the end, I was grouped up as a, as, because there's only one, like the highest rank is one above all.
And a pro player for Marvel Rivals can also be one above all.
Or like someone that was in the tier one scene in any other game, you know, if they were in a tier one scene in Apex and Overwatch, stuff like that.
They are still, they're in the same category as me.
And so Twitch was like, we can put you in a different team with people I don't even know who they are.
I don't know who they are, because they were looking for one more high ranker for their team.
And I was like, I, I'm gonna not, I cannot perform.
Also, I don't know who they are, and I don't feel comfortable with stuff like that.
I need like at least one person I know.
And it was like a full team of randoms that I don't know.
And like, obviously, I joined Twitch Rivals hoping to play with people I know.
And, um, and so like, I was like, no, I don't want to do that.
Like, um, I know my skill level.
I'm gonna be playing support too.
All the high rankers on the other teams are DPS and tank.
They are put in the slot of DPS and tank.
And, um, I would be like one of the few high rankers that would be put on support.
So obviously, they won't, it would be not a great experience.
And I'm worried that I'll be blamed for it.
You know, this person that they're not, like, they don't know who this person is.
They were randomly assigned me as their teammate.
And then, you know, I'd be blamed for it and stuff like that.
Um, it was such a tough situation.
So it was, I cut two of my teammates.
So like, for those who want more context, it was like, originally, you can only bring two diamond plus players and then the rest has to be diamond and below.
And then they adjusted the rules to make it four diamond plus players and two platinum below.
But I joined last minute when the rules where I was like the last three captains that were invited, basically, because when I was invited, all the other captains were already invited for like weeks already.
Um, everyone else were basic had already had a clap captain slot for that held it for weeks.
I had the captain slot when there was only three spots left for captains.
So that's how last minute I was invited in.
And I only knew the rules when it was four diamond plus players like you can bring so I didn't even realize they increased the players for it.
I didn't realize that.
That's why the people were like, some teams only had two diamond plus players, but your team has four, and they're one above all.
But like, I didn't know.
I didn't know they changed the rules.
Um, and, uh, because of that, um, I just went with and I saw the team's list.
And I already saw that some people were already, uh, that some people were already making it so that, uh, it was already getting stacked.
And I heard like murmurs about how they are stacking it.
And I heard people were getting, uh, I got scared too.
Because I heard people were getting multiple Apex players or old Overwatch pros or old Overwatch Apex player, like over Apex pros to be their platinum below players.
So I got scared too.
I was like, oh my God, this is getting very competitive.
It was getting, it was starting to get more and more competitive.
So I was like, well, like, I don't want to get shit on.
I, I'm, I've known from my history of doing Twitch rivals.
I am also my, uh, yeah.
And like my golden plat players.
It's Kony from F who's does fighting games.
And then, uh, Sabubu who has never touched rivals or Overwatch before.
Um, so I was like, yeah.
And there was, it was a 200K prize pool.
So I thought it was just going to be like, just like before, like, you know, I thought it was just going to be like all the other Twitch rivals I joined.
Where I was told it was going to be casual, but it's not.
I legitimately thought that cause I, I went through all of that shit like so many times.
Remember when I got invited to the Minecraft tournament?
And then like, I got made fun of for not being a Minecrafter and for sub making it far.
I was like, they're like, they're like, it's so dumb that these random people can be in our tournament.
In a Twitch rivals.
I was like, bro, what the fuck?
Um, I'm just like, I was like, bro, what the fuck?
I'm in this call.
Like,
oh my God.
I was like, what the fuck?
And then when I was in that Fortnite Twitch rivals and like, I got into this, you know, I was told it was going to be a casual Fortnite Twitch rivals.
By the way.
And then they're like, wait, you don't even play for it.
And I was like, oh no, I thought this was just for fun.
And they're just like, I felt so bad for my team.
Cause they're like, oh my God, she's not even, she doesn't even stream on Twitch or play Fortnite.
And they're like, how did you get in here?
And I'm like, I don't know.
I thought this was going to be casual.
I didn't know this was going to be trier.
I thought it was going to be the same.
I legitimately thought this was just going to head towards this direction.
It was most, I was like, oh no, okay.
I'm going to grab a team.
I'm just going to grab a team that follows that, that still, that follows the guidelines.
But like, I don't want to get spawn camped.
I don't want...
I was like, um...
So, they changed the rules again.
There's still teams with multiple TN players right now, which I don't understand what they changed, rather than removing you.
Marco, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, the last 24 hours before the tournament, they changed the rules again.
Where, uh...
Basically, the last 24 hours.
And this is why I dropped out.
Um, it's that you can have only 2 plus Eternity players.
And my team had 4 one above all players, including me.
So, because of that, a team can be basically 6 GM players if they...
Oh wait, it can be, sorry, it can be 4 GM players.
It can be 4 GM1 players.
Um, if they wanted to.
So, it's just bypass the Eternity thing.
It could be 4 GM players, or maybe like 3 GM players and 1 Celestial.
Um, as long as like, or like Eternity plus 3 GM players and then 1 one above all.
And it'll still be okay.
Or 2 GM players and 2 one above alls.
That's still fine.
As long as they have 2 players who are below plat.
Plat and below.
So, because of that...
So, for those who don't know what GM is, GM is Grand Master.
So, Grand Master is a rank below Eternity.
Um...
So, you can do that.
So, uh...
So, basically, um, I am one above all.
I am one above all.
Um, and...
We have 3 other players that are one above all.
My team was consisting of streamers that wanted to have an opportunity.
I was the biggest streamer in the team.
So, obviously, I have the bigger fan base.
I have the bigger CCV count and all of that.
And that really matters for Twitch.
Because...
Twitch rivals can only exist if they have people with huge CCV numbers.
Um, and with people watching the streamers that are participating in Twitch Rivals.
So, they want the big streamers.
They want the big streamers participating.
Because more CCV numbers means more sponsors.
It makes the sponsors more happy.
It's a 200k prize pool.
Where do you think that money is coming from?
The sponsors.
So...
CCV is concurrent views.
So, um...
Because of that...
Of course, they want to make sure that, uh...
The tournament...
They want everybody to stream the tournament too, by the way.
They want, uh...
Everybody to be able to stream the tournament.
So, they want people to have as much concurrent viewers.
Uh...
Sykkuno is back in the tournament.
Because of the role change.
Because his highest rank was GM.
So, uh...
Nekros team had to boot out two one above all players.
So, like, he had to...
I think it was like KG and ML7.
So, they're support players.
And they got in, like, subs.
The fills.
To help sub in.
So, Sykkuno is back in.
Because his highest rank was GM.
Um...
And...
Uh...
So...
Because of...
Uh...
So, my team...
Um...
Obviously, they wanted to keep me.
Because I was the most...
The highest CCV on the team.
And I bring in a different fan base.
Watching the tournament too.
So, like...
Obviously, they would want me in the tournament.
But...
I was one above all.
And...
I wasn't gonna kick...
A person...
A teammate...
That...
Obviously, needed the exposure more.
And the money more.
It's literally a 200k prize pool.
$200,000.
And...
Um...
You win regardless.
You can get money.
Despite how you do.
So, even if you lose...
You get money.
Even if you win, you get more money.
But if you lose...
You...
The least amount of money you'll get from this tournament...
Is $2,000.
The most you can get from this tournament...
Is $5,000.
So, like...
Each player, by the way.
Each player...
And...
I knew...
That this tournament...
Since it's the first tournament...
There's gonna be a lot of eyes on it.
Especially now that there's so much drama.
Like, everybody's gonna be watching it now.
Like...
Even though if you don't wanna support it, just don't watch it.
It's...
Just like how if you don't wanna support, like...
Something, just don't buy merch.
That's basically it.
Like...
So...
Um...
Anyway...
So, like...
Uh...
That's why I'm also streaming it.
Cuz I don't wanna give a view.
I was like, I'm not gonna watch it.
And I told one of the members to just, like, keep me updated.
Like, I was just like, just tell me if you win or not.
I'm not watching it.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
So, um...
I was just like...
I was like, just...
Just...
I'm not hate-watching.
I'm not...
I'm not giving a plus one.
I'm not hate-watching.
Texas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you wanna support my team, feel free to watch them.
I'm just not watching because I'm petty like that.
Even if it's plus one view, I'm not watching.
I refuse...
I refuse to give them my plus one.
Like...
But, like, if you wanna support my team, please feel free to watch them.
I believe it's Super Gomez, Hugs, Kony, Supubu.
I don't know who they got for the two fills because I just, like, tuned it out.
Like, I literally shut it off after I got...
After I dropped out.
Chicory, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
What a such a cold harsh night.
Even though tomorrow's sun soon rises.
As always, definitely.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, so, like...
Basically, I dropped out.
I chose to drop out.
I know, like, Sanhiko wrote that I got kicked out.
But, no.
I chose to drop out.
Because if I didn't drop out, I would have to kick out...
As captain, I would have to kick two people out.
I would rather kick one person out than two.
Because I don't wanna take away a smaller streamer's opportunity.
To, like...
Yes, technically, you can say I got kicked out.
Because I kicked myself out.
So, you know, you can technically say that.
I kicked myself out.
Like I said, if they make it to the finals, a lot of people will be watching.
Because Marble Rivals is also doing drops right now.
So, if they make it to the finals...
A lot of people will be watching my team's streams.
And I believe...
Especially some of them are content creators within Marble Rivals.
So this is basically...
It could become their big break.
You know?
That's what I feel like.
This could be their big break into the streaming world.
And they're very good at the games they master.
So, like, they're really good players.
And I don't need the exposure as much.
I don't need the clout.
I don't need the money.
Technically, I'm getting drama clout right now.
But it wasn't intentional.
I swear to God.
It was not intentional.
I needed to let you guys know.
I didn't want you guys to be like...
Doki, where are you?
Why aren't you in the tournament?
So, like...
I had to let you guys know that I'm not gonna be there.
And I had to be clear about, like, why I'm not there.
Yeah.
So...
So, I was like...
I just wanted you guys to know, like, why I wasn't...
As the captain, why I wasn't participating anymore.
I am...
I am gonna say that, like, I am sad that I couldn't participate.
Because, like, you guys all know...
I was really, really, really looking forward to...
No, it was crazy.
After the drama shit, I saw my fucking following count, like, go up by a thousand.
And I was like, what the fuck?
No wonder people keep farming drama.
It's just that easy.
It wasn't intentional.
I swear to God, it wasn't.
That's crazy.
I was like, oh my God.
Is this why people do this?
Yeah.
Anyway.
Doki moment.
Oh my God.
Catch me on the news next month, guys.
Please, no.
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
I hate it.
I was so sad last night.
I was like...
I actually cried an hour straight.
Because I know it was my decision to drop out.
But I still cried.
Because, like, I was incredibly...
I was looking forward to this.
I was really looking forward to playing.
Because I practiced a lot.
I practiced a lot.
And, like, I was...
Honestly, I was, like, really, really looking forward to playing in the tournament setting.
Because it's, like, the first major tournament.
And I thought it was going to be, like, super competitive and stuff like that.
So, of course, I got really sad.
I actually cried an hour after, like, hearing the announcement.
And then after I finished crying, my event coordinator was like...
I know you're feeling really shitty right now.
But you have a tech rehearsal for your convention tomorrow.
And we can't really reschedule it.
And I was like...
Okay.
I'm okay.
I can do this.
I was just, like...
I'm, like...
I can say...
And I'm, like, I'm sad.
They're like...
Oh, can you practice singing real quick?
We really...
So, like, during the tech rehearsal, I had to, like...
I had to, like, go do, like, practice, like, see if the soundcheck was okay for karaoke and the panda.
And they're like...
Can we hear you sing?
So we know, like, if the instrumental and your voice would be, like, okay.
And then I was like...
I can't.
I'm sorry.
But I can be, like...
I can talk in, like, a louder voice.
It's sort of like singing.
So they're like...
Oh, yeah, that works.
That works, Doki.
So I was like...
Hello.
This is what the volume was singing.
Okay, that's good.
Thank you.
Thanks, Doki.
I was like...
Testing.
While the instrumental...
While, like, be prepared instrumental was playing in the background.
I was like...
Testing.
This is the voice I'll be singing with.
And it's like...
Be prepared.
Like, that instrumental was playing in the background while I was doing all that.
Yeah.
And then...
And...
So I was not okay.
And then today...
I didn't forget.
But, like, obviously I...
Depression slept last night.
And, like, when you're...
When you're sad sleeping...
You...
Obviously, like...
When you wake up...
It's...
You...
You obviously are not there.
So...
I actually almost was late.
Because...
I didn't set any alarm.
And then, like...
My manager...
My...
My manager called me to wake me up.
But, like...
I didn't pick up.
I was just like...
What the fuck is my manager calling me at 7 in the morning?
What kind of freak is he?
I was like...
Goddamn freak calling me at 7.50?
What's wrong with you?
Of course I'm not gonna, like...
What?
So I didn't pick up.
I...
I didn't...
I didn't pick up the phone.
Because of it.
So...
And then I was looking at my Discord messages.
And then right after I didn't pick up...
My manager was like...
You have a meet and greet in 7 minutes.
And I was like...
Like...
The message?
And I was like...
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
I was like...
Oh shit!
And then I looked at my Discord...
Again.
And...
And I was like...
And then I was like...
Oh my god!
20 new messages!
Oh my...
I was like...
Oh my god!
They're like...
And then it was just...
It was just like...
Like my event coordinator being like...
Where are you?
They're like...
Hello?
And then they were like...
This is the last message my event coordinator sent me.
They were like...
Hello?
It's before the messages.
It was just like...
Hey, are you ready in 30 minutes?
They need to do...
They also...
By the way, they're gonna need to do like...
Check...
Sound check and stuff like that.
And then, you know...
Last 10 minutes, they just wrote...
Hello?
Yeah.
You know, there was just...
I was like...
I'm so sorry.
They're like...
No, we understand what happened last night.
We...
We understand.
I'm like...
I'm so sorry.
I'm here now.
Like...
A lot of stuff happened.
I'm sorry.
But I'm here now.
Oh my god.
It was just really poor timing overall.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're great.
Go back.
Go back to Final Fantasy VII.
Yeah, you look like a chocobo in the engineering way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Shady, thank you for the super chat.
The only person who kicked me out is me.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Anyway, I'm also not the only person that kicked themselves out as captain.
J3 also kicked himself out as well.
Because he also wanted...
Similar to me.
I think he saw like what I said about like...
Oh, I think like...
And then, he's like...
I think he also kicked himself out.
So that his teammates could also get exposure and stuff.
So, he was the captain.
So, J3 was also a captain for his team.
And I believe he was also like the biggest streamer for his team as well.
And he too also decided to like...
Kick himself out.
So that he didn't have to kick out like his other...
Other one about like Eternity Plus players.
So, yeah.
I wasn't the only one that did it.
J3 did as well.
Which was also...
I felt like was really nice of him to do as well.
But yeah, like...
So, that was basically the whole mess of everything.
Like I said, I...
I dropped out for my team.
Because I just didn't want to kick out two of my teammates.
Because they were very excited.
Like in the group chats, they were very excited.
They were like, let's try and win this.
Let's try and get to the finals.
Let's get to Day 2.
Like, let's make it to the quarterfinals.
Or like the finals, quarterfinals.
And they all trained really, really hard.
They were actually doing like VOD reviews.
And like scouting and stuff.
Like seeing what strategies people were using.
Trying to see what strategies to use and stuff like that.
And I just didn't want to take that away from them.
And...
And I thought that like, you know...
I was already very lucky with my career.
Like, I'm very lucky with my career.
And...
I am very fortunate to have you guys as my fans.
To have my Dragoons with me.
To support me through everything.
I can do variety.
I'm very lucky to be able to do variety.
I'm also very lucky to force you guys to let me take you guys hostage.
And force you guys to watch 16 hours of Marvel Rivals.
For three days straight.
I'm very lucky.
I can make you do anything.
In terms of watching any types of my streams.
A lot of people don't have that type of...
Don't have that type of community.
Or like...
Doki, please.
A lot...
A lot of people don't have that opportunity.
And...
Like I said, this Twitch Rivals...
For them, is basically their big break.
It's also maybe like their very first Twitch Rivals ever.
This might be my...
I mean, I didn't even participate in it.
What was my...
I can't believe Minecraft could have been my very fucking last Twitch Rivals.
That fucking is so...
I can't believe it.
I don't know.
I don't know if that bridge is burnt down.
I was very disappointed.
I got...
The head Twitch Rivals organizer...
Got in a call with me to try and apologize.
Being like...
You don't understand.
Like, checking everybody's rankings and stuff like that.
It's...
You know, it's a lot of work.
It's very hard to do.
And stuff.
And...
And they tried to apologize.
They tried to say like...
We would love to have you in the next Marvel Rivals tournament.
But like...
Or like in the next Marvel Rivals.
I don't know.
I don't know if the bridge is burnt down.
I think like...
I cut the rope.
But I don't know if they can...
Like, piece the rope back together.
I cut the rope on my end.
But like...
I don't know if it's fixable.
Cause like...
I was very mad.
I...
Cause...
I would understand...
If like...
I didn't do anything...
To make...
To avoid it.
If I just gave them the team.
And just never checked again.
You know?
But...
I was concerned too.
I was concerned.
Is my team too high-elo?
And...
I tried everything I could...
To make sure...
If like...
It was okay.
And...
Um...
I...
And like...
I did everything I can...
To like...
Uh...
To like make sure that...
You know...
Uh...
Things wouldn't go that way.
But it ended up going that way.
And...
It sucked that it was...
24 hours.
I would've been okay if they even gave me 2 days notice.
You know?
I...
I would've been fine.
If it was 2 days.
But it was 24 hours.
I...
The day before...
That...
24 hour notice...
I...
Did a...
2 hour scrim...
And a 2 hour VOD review.
I can't take that back.
I'm a very busy woman.
Like...
I'm very busy.
I can't take those hours back.
If I do...
That's it.
Yeah.
Um...
Yeah, so...
It's just like...
If I knew...
I would not have done that.
And...
I remember...
That day I was so busy.
Cause I had...
What did I have?
I remember I was so busy that day too.
And I still went to the scrim.
And like...
Did a VOD review.
Despite like...
My schedule was so fucked up.
Like...
Alright.
Oh yeah.
That was after God of War.
I was so tired.
Literally...
I...
That was...
Right after God of War too.
Like...
So...
Right after God of War.
I had 30 minute break.
And then I went to scrims.
And then I did a VOD review.
And then thinking...
That everything is okay.
Yeah.
I thought...
You know...
Right after God of War.
I could rest.
But...
Especially after finding out...
That Artanis was Loki.
And I raised a fucking disappointment.
I couldn't.
I couldn't process that.
I had to go straight to Rivals.
I couldn't process that my son was Loki.
So...
That's why...
It gave me two days notice.
I would've been okay.
I would've been fine.
I would've been mad as mad.
I would've still kicked myself out.
But like...
I wouldn't be as mad.
I wouldn't.
Dan, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
But yeah.
That's why I was like...
Extra disappointed.
And extra like...
Mad about the whole situation.
And then like...
Yeah, so...
Yeah, it was just...
It was just all over the place.
The organization.
But like I said...
Like...
I really, really wanted to...
I really, really wanted to give...
The smaller streamers a chance to participate.
Because I don't know if you know this.
But...
Twitch Rivals...
Tend to be like the same people.
Including me.
Like, obviously I take advantage of that.
Because it's like...
Free money.
And also like...
Also the fact that like...
I can also bring...
Sometimes they give me a chance to bring my own team.
And...
Because of that, sometimes I...
You know, I include someone that I know.
Someone I know, someone I'm comfortable with.
But I also try to include people who are smaller streamers.
Because...
A lot of small streamers...
The only chance to get into Twitch Rivals for the small streamers...
Is basically...
Being invited by a captain.
And that's really rare.
It's really rare for that to happen.
Because obviously...
We all want to invite our friends.
We all want to invite our friends, but sometimes like...
You know, we want to invite friends who are really good at the game or something.
And stuff like that.
Or we want to invite people we want to network with.
Like, sometimes I have to think about that too.
Like, oh, do I want to invite this person?
Like, as a chance to network with them.
Stuff like that.
So, it's all about that.
But it tends to be around, you know...
So, being in Twitch Rivals...
For a small streamer...
Is an incredible opportunity.
Like, it's basically a goal or a dream for some of them.
So...
And like I said, the reason why...
They actually want you to invite...
Your friends or people with bigger streamers.
Because...
The bigger numbers you have for Twitch Rivals...
The happier the sponsors are.
So like...
So like, that's basically the whole deal.
Like, that's how most...
That's why for my tournament...
Sometimes I do invite bigger content creators.
Because I want to make, you know, the sponsors happy.
I want to make sure, like, you know...
But I try to balance out with smaller content creators too.
Like, it's a mix between big content creators and smaller content creators.
Because, you know...
I want to let people know, like...
Hey, here are the numbers I can get when I host an event.
And host a tournament.
To encourage sponsorships.
To encourage people to sponsor this again.
Or like, encourage new sponsors to fund my events.
Stuff like that.
But I still want to mix between small content creators and big content creators.
But if I'm self-funding it...
If I'm self-funding it...
I don't care about what numbers.
Obviously.
Like, WrestleTuber.
I invited big content creators.
I invited smaller content creators.
Because, like...
I'm self...
Like, a lot of it was self-sponsored.
And then, like, other...
Like, Gamersubs helped in as well.
Gamersubs helped in.
But when I first started the idea, it was all, like, my idea.
And then Gamersubs came in to help fund majority of my ideas.
And then...
They were okay with the numbers.
Because it was just on my channel.
So everything just funnels into my channel.
The numbers-wise.
So it appeased the sponsors.
That's basically how tournaments work.
It's all about making sure they can have...
They get enough numbers.
So it makes sponsors happy.
And then they can continue to host these events.
So they can continue to, like, host these events.
And continue to have funding for these events.
And stuff like that.
That's basically how tournaments and events work.
Unless they're self-funded.
If you're self-funded, you don't care.
You are your own sponsor.
Like...
I am my own sponsor.
Who fucking cares?
As long as the fans enjoy it.
That's all I care about.
But...
But yeah.
So this is, like, basically the insight of everything that happened.
Like, it was just a shitshow overall.
Like, of course, if you have a 200k prize pool.
You cannot make a 4 fun tournament.
Like...
There's no way.
It's 200k!
I don't need that money.
But, like, to other people, that's a lot of money.
It's like that Minecraft Twitch Rivals.
With what?
500k?
To what?
What was it?
500k?
And one person wins 100k?
No, what was it?
Oh my god.
Wait, no.
Was it?
I don't remember.
Was it 100k?
It was like, one person wins 100k.
Like...
Whoa!
And it was...
And the finals was Connect 4.
Oh my god.
That shit was wild.
They made the finals Connect 4.
And then, the two players that made it to the...
For those who didn't watch the Twitch Rivals Minecraft series...
Nobody wins...
Other than the people who make it to the finals.
So, only...
Out of, like...
How many players?
Out of, like, 100...
200 players?
Was it 200 players?
I think it was more than 200 players.
It was a lot of people.
It was not 100.
I remember.
It was not 100 people.
And...
And they invited people from all over.
So, it wasn't just Minecrafters.
So, I got invited.
But there was also other people that I invited that were just not...
Normal people.
Like, not normal players.
And...
And, like...
But then, like...
You can only get the money if you make it to top 16 or something.
The person who wins the tournament...
Gets, like...
100k.
Only top 30 got money.
And the final...
Was it 50 or 100k, guys?
I don't remember.
Like, the number blurs together.
But it was a lot of money.
Only one winner can get, like, the big prize pool.
And it was either 50k or 100k.
And then...
During the finals...
The finals finals was Connect 4.
And...
And because it was Connect 4...
The two remaining players...
Forced a stalemate...
Out of rebellion for this tournament.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
It was 100k to first place.
And second place gets 10k.
Is that shit fucking crazy?
That is not for fun at that point.
That is not.
Yeah, so, like...
They were, like...
They were so frustrated with how the entire tournament was run...
That the last two players...
Forced a 30...
What was it?
It was, like...
One to two hours overtime.
They made the fucking entire event...
One to two hours longer.
And, like...
Just doing draws.
Because it was Connect 4.
So they could just do draws.
Like, they just kept fucking tying.
Over and over...
And over again.
And it was... Okay.
But it was, like, pure cinema.
Because it was, like...
The English community versus the Spanish community.
So it was pure cinema.
Because they united together.
To work together.
For the evil...
It was, like...
The English community, Minecraft community, and the Spanish Minecraft community...
Working together to take down...
To take down...
The higher-ups.
To fight against the man.
To fight against Big Corpo.
So...
It was actually pure cinema.
You guys missed out on that era.
But, yeah.
Like I said.
I don't know how I feel...
Currently, regarding Twitch.
I know, like, my manager really wanted me to stream...
Like, at least once or twice...
Twice...
Once or, like...
Twice a...
Once a week.
Or every other week.
But I don't know.
Other than that, it soured my entire mood over Twitch at the moment.
So, like...
I might stay on YouTube.
I might just be on YouTube.
Just, you know...
Just chill on YouTube.
And stuff for a bit.
Just to cool down.
I got so mad that I actually, like...
Unfollowed...
Unfollowed, like, one or two people.
Because they were, like...
They were, like...
Dick-sucking...
Twitch rivals.
And I was just like...
Fuck that.
Macken won't see this on my feed.
Like...
I was like...
I literally...
That was how mad I was yesterday.
I was so...
I was just like...
I was like...
Give criticism...
Like...
Don't, like, just...
Don't just...
Because, like...
Okay.
This is how my mindset goes.
Like...
They deserve criticism.
On that part.
Like...
I was legitimately...
Was like...
Like, you can fucking...
Like, I don't know.
You can, like...
Like...
Like, suck your dick.
Because, like...
Your life...
You know, your...
Your entire career is on Twitch.
You know?
You can't burn that bridge.
I'm lucky for the fact that, like...
I can be on YouTube.
Like, I'm primarily on YouTube.
So, like...
Like, if that bridge is burnt down...
At least I still have YouTube.
Um...
So, like...
It makes sense for them to, like...
To be, like...
You know...
To, like...
Cover for them.
But I'm, like...
But...
Yesterday, in my head...
I was, like...
Look...
They actually deserve criticism on that part.
That was, like...
Really fucked up.
Like...
And...
I was, like...
I was really...
Really messed up.
Like...
They deserve criticism.
You can't defend every...
There's...
You can defend...
But you have to give criticism when it's valid.
And that...
I felt like that was the moment...
When it was incredibly valid.
Like...
Um...
So, like...
Uh...
Yeah.
I was just, like...
I know some people were, like...
Oh, yeah.
Valkyrie.
No.
It was not Valkyrie's fault.
Um...
She gave criticism.
And it was...
It was, like...
Good criticism.
Um...
And then...
She was also not happy that they changed their roles...
Within the last 24 hours.
It was...
Like...
This was her first Twitch Rivals.
Apparently, this was...
Her very first Twitch Rivals.
And nobody...
Like...
Nobody on staff told her...
That, like...
They were planning on changing their roles.
And stuff.
Too.
Like...
They kept changing their roles.
If they didn't...
If they kept the original...
Two GM players...
Like...
Two...
Uh...
Diamond Plus players...
It would have been fine.
But they changed it...
And they flipped back.
So, like...
Like...
That was the...
That was the biggest issue.
And...
Ray was also mad.
That...
That, like...
They changed their roles within the last 24 hours.
Because they kept flip-flopping.
Too.
Um...
So, like...
It's not like...
Uh...
Like...
People were complaining.
But they were all valid criticism.
Uh...
And, like...
So, that's why I was very mad.
Like...
I was like...
You can, like...
Fucking...
I don't know...
Dick ratting...
Like...
All you want.
But, like...
I don't want to see that on my feed.
When I'm mad.
When I'm mad...
Like...
I was like...
I don't want to see that.
Like...
Like, I don't care.
You...
Clearly.
I know that you rely on Twitch for your career and you want to be on their good side.
But, if you keep...
If you don't criticize them, they will never improve.
Because they think they can just brush this underneath their rug and it'll be fine.
Like, why- they will never change if you just let them keep doing what- if you just, like, you know...
Um, let them do whatever and just roll- I wasn't gonna get rolled over, that is why.
I was not rolling over, like...
I'm done with rolling over, like...
I- I was... yeah.
I was- I was so- I was not- I was not fucking standing up for myself, like...
Like, I let them fucking walk over me from the other Twitch arrivals, cause I just laughed it off.
And now, like, this was a game I was really passionate about.
And I- like, I actually was like, I really wanna do well.
Like, I really wanna do well.
I really enjoy- I really enjoy Marvel Rivals.
And I was so passionate about it.
I worked really hard practicing for it- for it.
I was like, I wasn't gonna roll- roll over this time.
Um, yeah.
So, like, that's basically- oh my god, sorry.
This has actually been, like, a one hour venting session.
I'm sorry, guys.
I- this is literally rent-free in my head.
Like, I'm sorry.
It's like, I'm- it's actually- Twitch is living rent-free in my head.
No, it's doing what they wanted!
It did- No!
I basically let them get in my head.
That's what they wanted.
No.
No, you're giving them attention!
You're supposed to ignore it!
Um...
Yeah, so, yeah, that's- sorry.
You guys are, like, my therapists right now, guys.
I'm sorry.
You guys- you guys are, like, my therapists.
I need to get through the day.
I-
I'm sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's just like, yeah.
So, yeah, that's- that's really it.
Like I said, like, I'm not on the main platform.
Like, Twitch isn't my main platform.
And I'm not the biggest streamer.
Like, I'm sort of like a nobody on Twitch.
So, like, my opinion doesn't really matter when it comes to, like, Twitch stuff.
So, uh, yeah, so like, it's understandable that, like, like, you know, fuck me, you know?
Um, but, uh, but I'm all right.
I feel a lot better, though.
I feel... I do feel a lot better.
Uh, stream, thank you for the magenta supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki professionals have standards.
Uh, Mr. Sen, thank you for the aka-supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for your service.
We're so proud of you.
Thank you, doki-supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Mori, thank you for the super chat.
As a therapist, as your therapist, I can remind you to take your meds.
Chat isn't real, except for Mori, apparently.
She was the only one I was talking to.
Uh, Liet, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Instead of paying for therapists, we pay you here.
We pay you here.
It's a small installment.
Thank you.
See, it's even better than therapy.
I get paid.
I get paid instead of paying thousands of dollars for one hour session.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Billy Bada, Billy Bada, dum-ba-da-dum, Billy Bada.
Sorry, my local chan canteen is open, stuck in my head.
Hope you're well, doki.
Thank you for the super chat, Brian.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Um, but yeah, I hope my team does well.
I hope they make it to the finals.
I hope they make it to the finals, even without me and Rai.
I believe Rai also dropped out.
Um, for his team.
Um, so I hope they do good and they make it to the finals, because honestly, um, they deserve it.
They deserve the exposure.
They deserve the clout and they deserve the money that comes with it.
So yeah, good luck to them.
Um, yeah, they're like, oh, oh my god.
Okay, this is one...
Oh my god, I...
Okay, like, I know, like, some of the people were offered, like, chances to co- they're like, you can co-stream it too, so you can get, like, a viewer, like, a viewer boost from the rivals.
I don't know why that would make me more incentivized to be okay with it.
Like, you can get a viewer boost from the Twitch rivals.
I put a play in it.
I don't fucking...
I was like, I don't care about the viewership numbers.
Like, I mean, I do care because I want to have a career.
Like, I still want to, I still need to pay bills, but like, I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't care.
I don't know.
I don't like, I don't like watching it.
Like, like, I guess I don't like doing watch-alongs of this shit.
Like, I feel like it made me sadder, honestly.
I- no, it would, it would, because I'd be like, I could be playing right now.
I would have definitely been more sad.
I'd be like, you could have been playing it, but here you are watching them win without you.
Like, that'd be, oh my god, that fucking FOMO's gonna hit me hard there.
Yeah, I didn't want to get hit by the FOMO there.
So I was like, no, I'm not, I'm gonna, I'm gonna stream my own thing.
I'm gonna go to YouTube, like, fucking, like, I'm gonna go back to YouTube and stream something there.
Like, um, um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I feel like I was gonna get on a chair right there.
Like, I feel like I have to sit in a chair, like, look at these people having fun without you.
Wow.
Oh, I was like, fuck that shit.
I just talked to my chat.
Like, uh, Mr. Kermit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, first time here and I just witnessed a therapy session.
Now I'm gonna, now I know this is, I'm sorry for the trauma dump, guys.
Trauma dump, trigger warning, twitch.
Now I know this is gonna be my next favorite streamer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Solace, thank you for your very first super chat.
Thanks to you, I became also addicted to Marble Rivals and became a Luna Snowman.
And your streams calmed me down before I made my driver's license.
Yeah, congratulations, you can drive now.
Congratulations, I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate that you were able to get your license.
Um, drive safely though.
Uh, GN, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Toki, no.
No, GN, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Liam, um, hypothetically, how much legal charcoal would you be in for streaming an official twitch event for on YouTube?
None.
I just stream like one of my teammates.
Like, it's, I live in NA.
We have, what is it called?
What is it called?
Fair use laws.
Like, I'm not gonna, okay, I won't like, you, like, if I do one, I won't just drag, like, Twitch Rivals official broadcast.
I just drag one of my team, what is my, what are my teammates gonna do?
Copyright strike me?
Like, after I sacrificed myself for them, they're really gonna fucking copyright strike me if I, if I, if I watch their POV.
Yo, thanks, yo, thanks for letting me stay on the team.
That would be wild.
Yeah, what a face teammate.
Um, Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We'll make our own tournament.
With tomatoes and memes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Original, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for taking a break from our lives.
Come to the con today.
My dumbass didn't even think to say my username in the meet and greet.
Thank you for the super chat, original.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, guys, it was, I'm so sorry if you were at the meet and greet and you got the, the meet and greet where you had to talk to me on the phone.
I mean, it did feel a little more, I was trying to sell it hard.
So, like, there was internet issues at first for the meet and greet.
So, it, we were, the meet and greet was literally done via phone call.
So, like, um, it was, like, one of the staff member's phone.
And I'll be like, oh my god, it's like we're having a personal phone call right now.
Phone call RP.
And I did feel really bad.
But fortunately, the convention staff, um, she spoke into your ears.
I hate you all.
But, um, um, anyway, anyway, I felt, like, really bad about it.
And just, like, it was supposed to be, like, on a monitor.
And, um, so, like, the staff, the staff told us, like, oh yeah, we, we, we told them it was okay.
They're all okay.
They can get a refund and stuff like that.
So, I was like, okay, that makes me feel a lot better, you know.
Like, I was like, oh my god, at least, like, a refund was offered.
But, um, after that, um, we swapped to the actual monitors.
I'm jealous more.
It's not professional, Dexy.
I can't, we can't have, guys, I don't know.
I feel like phone call meeting greets just feels like, it just, it just feels like budget.
Like, you know, I feel really bad because they paid for it, too.
And I feel like you paid for, like, a phone call.
Um, um, we won the phone call experience.
Um, but yeah, yeah, we can corner the market.
I still have a chance.
Please speak into my ears next.
Okay, Navi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cass, thank you for the super chat.
Mushy Mushy, is this Doki bird?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, um, Dania, thank you for the super chat.
Doki rivals tournament win.
Do only small concurrents so it's not so pricey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I like having a mix of both so that, like, you know, it's easier to host more of them in the future, too.
Uh, Shia, thank you.
And I also like, you know, having, you have, okay, here's the reason why you have to mix both.
If you have all smalls, small streamers, no, I'm so sorry, but like, you won't have a lot of eyes on that tournament.
So it's also good, the bigger CCTV is also good, so that's why I like to mix, have a mixture of both.
So, you know, if there's bigger content creators and smaller content creators, you know, it allows a chance for the smaller content creators to have a chance to shine in front of the audience from the bigger content creators.
So, like, so that's why I like having both, like, just try to have, like, a mixture of both in there.
Um, Shrom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're trying to reach you about your car's extended warranty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Melio, thank you for the super chat.
Is this Doughkeeper?
No, this is Patrick.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Coyote, thank you for the super chat.
Scuff only makes it feel even more exactly.
It's more authentic to the Doughkeeper experience.
Gia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Paying for this kind of scuff in my meet and greet, you're like, please, internet, be shitty, so I can have my phone call meet and greet, so I can talk to her on the phone.
Oh my god, we're tight like that.
Honestly, true.
You're like, please, internet, be shitty, so I can call her on the phone.
When do we get text message meet and greet?
Oh my god.
Okay, that's not super chat.
I read it because that just... Do you know, like, okay, I know this because I have a friend who's friends with OnlyFanModels and, like, okay, I'm gonna, like, okay, I'm sorry if you subscribe to Only...
Like, if you're an OnlyFan subscriber, but, like, I'm here to break your fucking world view.
But, like, I don't know if this is, like, an ad.
Like, I don't know if this is, like, supposed to be, like, a company secret, but if it is, that's right.
See me on the news next month.
I'm exposing everything.
Now I know how to do it.
Anyway, um, um, so, like, you know how, like, some OnlyFan girls, they would do it so that they would be, like, you pay more, you get more, uh, you get, uh, like, personal DMs from personal DMs from, like, the OnlyFanModels.
You're not getting it from the OnlyFanModels.
A lot of them actually, like, hire assistants, sometimes men, to, like, DM, like, reply back to, like, hundreds of people and, like, pretend fake RP.
Oh, it's them as the model!
Yeah, so, like, um, it's, yeah, so, it's, like, they pay, like, $500 more so you can have a personal one-on-one talk with one of the models, but it's not actually, it's never actually them.
It's...
Like, I didn't, no, I didn't know, because I was like, you can just do that?
Lie on the internet like that?
Like, because they give a super chat, they can take 1-900, don't keep your chat line.
I was like, oh my god, like...
And then they would, like, roleplay and pretend to be the girl and stuff, and they'll, like, just, uh, um, who would I thought?
I don't know, because I would think, like, oh my god, if, like, a guy pays, like, a thousand dollars to have a chance to, like, talk to somebody personal one-on-one, and it's, I just, I don't know, I'm too pure.
I would be like, you can just scam them like that?
Like, like... But then I was like, but it makes sense, because, like, hundreds of men are also playing, like, or women, you know, are women.
Some women likes what they see, and they'll just be, like, you know, hundreds of them pay, like, a thousand plus dollars.
So, like, obviously, you don't have the time to, like, RP to, like, you know, sex them.
Um...
So, yeah, you could be chatting up some fucking poor assistant that's barely being paid a minimum wage, um, that's, like, fake RP, role-playing with you, and be like, yeah, man, that's so hot, oh my god, and they're just, like, sitting up, like, and they're just,
like, sitting on their PC on, like, in an office space, just, like, with a cigarette in their hand, and, like, um, a cigarette and coffee on the other, and just be, like, oh my god, that's so hot, like, what else do you want to do?
And then after they finish typing that, they tab to a different conversation, and be, like, what are you wearing, and then they swap to another tab, and be, like, oh my god, are you done yet?
Like, they just keep, they just, like, swapping tabs and everything, and and then, and then on a separate tab, they're out there playing, like, Minesweeper while they're, they're, like, waiting for the next reply, and just playing Minesweeper at their desk,
or, like, reading through Twitter, scrolling through Twitter and stuff, and just be, like, oh, oh shit, Michael replied, what did they say?
All right, okay, okay, a $50 tip, what does a $50 tip give?
All right, okay, um, send a panty picture, opens a folder with hundreds of panty picture, but you tell them, oh, I just took this for you, copy-paste, like,
how they would think it's personal, but then it's a folder full of pre-made pictures.
Um, um, all right,
I mean, they didn't lie, you're destroying their immersion, um,
damn, Michael, you're a freak, sorry, where I put that folder?
Solid steak, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
They have automated messaging, as well as prompts and guides for texting and upping stuff is, how do you know that even?
Solid snake, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, but also, how do you know so much too?
How do you know about these guides and upping prices?
I like how some people are like, oh my god, wait, that sounds, how do I get started being an assistant for an OnlyFans girl?
He's, snake, do you work for one?
Um, uh, Usagi, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You're holding out on us with that phone roleplay, huh?
I respect for sticking to your guns, kid.
You made the right decision, of course, I'm nobody, so take that for what it's worth, and I won't play some rounds, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, um, wait, solid snake, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I am the one that mods this.
Wait, wait, real?
Wait, oh my god, what I think is funny is that you do that, you get paid, and you come here to super chat.
You're like, make this, oh my god, you give me dirty money.
It's all right, it's all right, I take all kinds of money.
It's all right, I take all kinds, I have, I'm shameless, I have no standards, that's okay.
I have no standards, guys, it's all right, all money is good money.
You do you.
I'll clean the money later.
It's like, it's like, it's like, you know, like...
Um, you know, like, the, I, like, it makes me think about, like, you know, like, you know, like people with dollar bills, and like, making it rain, and then the strippers have to, like, you know, take that money, and then use that money later, and then,
but they don't know, we don't know when they use, they're like, this is stripper money, but you don't know it's stripper money, because like, how would you know?
Like, you could hold up a dollar bill, and be like, one dollar bill, and be like, has this been on a stripper?
You don't know, unless it's new, new bills, and this...
Money is money, you don't know that, this dollar bill could have gone anywhere.
This dollar bill could have gone anywhere.
Um, look, work is work, plus you get insurance?
Okay, where do you, where do we sign up?
I, what if I, that could be my side hustle, just for the insurance.
Whoa, that's better than, like, other jobs here.
Like, honestly, a job that gives you insurance is so much better than anything, than a lot of jobs.
Do you get dental?
Do you, dude, look, I, can I give them my CV?
You, you lucky motherfucker.
Blazing gun, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I work at a Taco Bell, and there is a strip club down the street, so I get those dollars a lot.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Like, I'm doing a chat, I was like, wait, you're hiring, are you hiring?
Oh my God, um, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, uh, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Holy shit, guys, these are like crucifax days.
Also, Mackle, I am not gonna read that, but what the fuck?
No, I've heard, I've heard, like, stories about that, too, because they're just like, or they just buy it off of, like, Amazon, and be like, I totally did that.
I'm like, holy shit, I'm back.
Okay, but, like, how much did she get?
There's, there has to be, there's no way she did it for less than a hundred grand.
There's no fucking way.
That's actually crazy, like, that's, that's so insane.
There's no way she'd do that for, okay, maybe a hundred grand, I'm asking too much.
I don't know if a hundred grand is something that means I'm asking way too much, but, like, I feel like, I feel, Jesus did not type for this.
Jesus did not type.
What a wild statement.
Oh my god, thank you for the super chat.
Oh my god, is that?
No, no, it's not.
I make enough to, thankfully, I'm not desperate.
Okay, I, I'm just happy the internet was a mistake.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm happy to make enough money where, like, I don't care about being a mill- I don't care about being a millionaire.
That's all I'm gonna say.
I don't care about being a millionaire.
I care more about having a million subscribers than I do about being a millionaire.
I like reinvesting into things.
I just want to be able to live comfortably.
I just want to be able to live- I'm not greedy for money.
I want my dog to be able to live comfortably.
I don't want to worry about the future or anything because she's a billionaire.
Don't listen to her.
So, like, I don't care.
I don't- I'm not gonna be like, I need to do all of this.
Like, I'm gonna die before I can use my millions of dollars.
Like, I'm not a millionaire, but, like, I'm gonna die before- What about your family or your future?
You're- you're, like, children's children's children.
Look, I- I don't care.
Like, Bill Gates doesn't give a fuck.
Why should- Okay, that's fucked up.
Bill Gates doesn't give money to his kids, so why should I?
Damn!
Whoa!
That's a bad example.
That's a mess.
Um, anyway.
Yeah, anyway, as I was- as I was saying, um, um, I just- I don't know.
I don't know.
I feel like maybe, like, I don't know.
I don't know if I would- I don't know.
I've always, like, been, like, fuck children.
Like, I- I don't know.
I don't know what's gonna happen in the future.
She's single forever.
I'm gonna be, like- I'm gonna be, like, 90.
And you know how, like, there's, like, crazy cat ladies?
Um, I'll be, like, a crazy- a crazy dog lady with, like, 10 wiener dogs.
Like, I'll be, like- And then- and then, like, when I cease to exist, I'd be, like, in my will.
I- I- I will the remains of my- my money to my 10 wiener dogs.
And-
They get to have- they get to have my- my- my house.
And, like, and the maid and the caretaker- Three- no, each wiener dog shall have their own caretaker.
And- And they shall be paid from the remains of my- my bank account.
But, uh, these- you- they must- they must carry on the Doe Keeper linguage.
And they must have children.
Uh, wait, don't be neutered, JK.
Don't be neutered.
But you shall must- if the caretaker's wiener dog dies, they must replace that wiener dog and continue his- his generation.
Until the caretaker retires.
Then, they shall- they must take care of the- their last remaining wiener dog until its death.
And they- Continue the bloodline.
Or I ran out of money in the bank account.
Or- It's that they either take care of the wiener dogs until they die.
Until, like, they retire.
And, like, they can keep the dog until- until it ceases to exist.
Or- or there's just no more money in the bank account.
Then I don't know what you're gonna do with the dog.
I don't- I don't know.
Then- and the care- oh, the care- Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The generational wiener dogs.
That's where my money's gonna go.
Um, Kaz, the caretakers will be buried with their wiener masters.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
MHS, thank you for the super chat.
Yep.
That's my Oshie.
Just like the Egyptians.
I'm bringing it back.
I don't know why we stopped in the first place.
Like, you know how, like, in Egyptian times, um, Can you adopt me?
I can be a wiener dog for you, my queen.
Navi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know in Egyptian times, every time, like, a royal person dies, they, like, kill their pets and, like, their- their favorite- their favorite servant and be like, you have to die for- Literally, that's- it's fucked up.
They're like, you shall- you- and if he dies, you die.
Hey, so they basically get, like, buried.
Uh, they get buried, um, with their owners and we should bring it- I don't know why we don't bring it back.
I don't- I feel like that's so romantic, guys.
I feel like- Toki, no.
Marsha, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My money comes from something far more serious.
The state of France.
Marsha, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All I'm saying is that I don't understand why we stopped doing that practice.
I thought it was a pretty neat practice.
That's all I'm saying.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I've been chatting for, like, so long.
We've been at it for a while now, but I really had a good time talking to you guys.
I had a great time just hanging out with everybody.
I didn't even call it here.
I just said this is gonna be, like, a pretty short stream today.
Um, I hope you guys had a fun time just listening to me yap.
Um, yap.
Even though it was short, I'm sorry it was really short, guys.
I'm really sorry.
Um, I do want to rest a little bit today.
Um, since now it is considering my free day, I'm gonna go rest now.
Uh, Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Toki, I had so much fun talking to you today.
I wanted to tell you so much and forgot because I had so much fun yapping with you.
Oh, baby, lucky enough to do this again one day.
Also, Miku Fortnite went.
Oh my god, Miku, Miku, ba-da-dum.
That was, like, that's been stuck in my head because it's the Fortnite skin now, but...
Thank y'all for coming.
Thank y'all for letting me.
I was gonna play Toroba today because that's why I was like, maybe I'll do some retail therapy.
But now I'm like, you know what?
No, we'll do that another time.
I bought, like, $30 of worth of, uh, points for it, but...
We'll do that another time.
Maybe we'll do it next week and have it an unofficial scheduled stream.
Um, um, anyway, guys, uh, uh, I had a great time talking to all you guys.
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me.
And I'll tell you, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for the financial advisement, everyone.
I'll consider the many options moving forward.
Go for the one that provides health insurance!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, Panzer, thank you for the super chat.
Uh, since I watch you at work, this is considered a business expense.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Riku, thank you for the super chat.
Guess it's a good thing that your brain is home.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, guys, I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!